dark blazer white shirt red or blue
pattern tie this is the unchanging
uniform of one Washington's most
respected insiders and the Justice
Department's pick to lead the
investigation into Russia's interference
in the 2016 election the choice of
robert muller for special counsel has
been met with unusual universal praise
from both sides of the aisle I think
he's a person of great integrity he'll
be above politics
you will not push him around completely
unimpeachable in all respects he will
investigate the matter and follow the
facts wherever they may lead from
decorated war hero to crusading
prosecutor to unyielding FBI director
this is how robert muller came to be
considered the least biased man in
America Robert Swan Muller the third
grew up in Philadelphia and attended
high school at the prestigious st.
Paul's School there he captained the La
Crosse soccer and hockey teams Moeller
attended Princeton where he majored in
politics before receiving a master's
from NYU the death of a former Princeton
lacrosse teammate in Vietnam drove
Muller to join the Marine Corps in
Vietnam he commanded a rifle platoon
receiving a number of decorations
including the Purple Heart
it wasn't the army or the Navy he was a
Marine he had the toughest most hardcore
of the Armed Forces that's Greg Ferrell
and reporter for legal affairs and
regulatory issues at Bloomberg after
getting his law degree from the
University of Virginia
moer rose quickly through the ranks as a
federal prosecutor as chief of the
Justice Department's Criminal Division
moer oversaw several high-profile cases
including Panama dictator Manuel Noriega
mafia boss John Gotti and the Lockerbie
bombing Moller had a quick stint in
private practice but it wasn't for him
he quit his job as a very highly paid
white-shoe law firm partner to prosecute
homicide cases in the nation's capital
that's the dedication that you could see
there in 2001 President Bush appointed
Muller to FBI director he is a bit of a
taskmaster he wanted to upgrade the
quality of the office and he did it
wasn't pleasant for everyone who was
there but it was something that needed
to be done
the FBI changed markedly under his
leadership exactly one week after
starting in 2001 the September 11th
attacks happened a lot of people viewed
him as being a very steady hand after
the Nunn Weber attacks that's Chris
Sturm Weinberg national security
reporter reshaping the FBI to become a
counterterrorism agency and also
building up cyber security and at the
end of Moore's 10-year tenure President
Obama moved for a special two-year
extension both times Muller was
nominated to run the FBI he was
unanimously approved by Congress it was
not all smooth sailing though mowers
principles were put to a significant
test in 2004 over President Bush's
warrantless surveillance program
secretly launched after September 11th
the secret surveillance program needed
to be reauthorized by lucerna general
who at that time was John Ashcroft and
Ashcroft was sick in the hospital on the
night of March 10th 2004 several
high-profile White House officials were
on their way to pressure Ashcroft to
sign papers extending the program when
ash grass wife interviewed she reached
out to Deputy Attorney General James
Comey hung up called director Muller and
told him what was happening he said I'll
meet you at the hospital right now in a
showdown at George Washington Hospital
all our employees do it side by side to
prevent officials from the Bush
administration from trying to force a
spur off to reauthorize the program
while laying in his hospital bed
threatening to resign mower and Comey
were able to get the program altered the
seeker program looked like they wouldn't
have come out shadows if smaller though
he didn't stand against mowers
long-standing relationship with Comey
has led to questions about whether he
can remain impartial in his current
investigation it's clear from his almost
forty years of public service that
Muller is dedicated to the job we'd have
to be pretty much a dead end er to not
believe Bob Muller and while
investigating allegations of collusion
between Trump and Russia may be his
toughest case yet yeah I think of
anybody who will be better than Mahler
to do the investigation he's had a
history of standing up to power he could
be that issue standing up as president
it's one of the most important jobs of
his life once again he's answering a
call
you